we are still on the parabola but we're
thinking about these same kinds of
features tangents and normals just
without worry about all of this
parameter stuff we're talking about so
therefore I can't call the point on the
parabola like 288 e squared I can't do
that because that requires the the T the
parameter okay so therefore I'm gonna
pick an arbitrary point on the parabola
and I'm just gonna call it x1 y1 it's a
me point you like okay so if this is the
case I can still use the calculus that I
know to find the gradient and therefore
the equation of the tangent or the
normal at this point if I've got this
set of coordinates what I do with those
to find the gradient at this point what
will I need okay so if you make Y the
subject you can then differentiate and
get the result you're talking about
so I've just made Y the subject here so
I can do this I wonder if it rings any
bells
that the derivative of this will be x on
to a X onto it okay now if this is the
gradient anywhere but this is the
particular point I am interested in then
that at this point the gradient will be
not X but X 1 on to a okay so now I can
put a box around this this is all the
information I need I've got a point I've
got a gradient let's see what kind of
equation we get out of this right so I'm
going to preface this by saying I am
working out the equation of the tangent
like so and I'm gonna do my normal you
know Y minus y1 etc and I'm gonna expand
out as I require so it looks something
like this
excuse me
now for here you're like well I usually
like to avoid fractions if I care so
I'll multiply everything through by 2a
that gives me this
now once you've written this you're like
okay now what like there aren't really
any like terms that I can collect this
is one of the distinct disadvantages of
using the Cartesian form because there's
no there's no simplification you could
do with these two they're so separate
they're so different
no no simplification can happen there
but we do have one little tiny unusual
trick up our sleeve put your pen down
from it because this is weird and
confusing what's the parabola I'm
dealing with at the moment what's the
equation of this parabola x squared
equals 4a Y that's the overall equation
okay now do you remember we were talking
about in the extension 1 AP 2 exam I
think you got trying to remember the
actual thing it was something like this
on a 9 plus 5 equal 0 and then we had to
do some stuff with some product of roots
do you remember that ok now one of the
things that was in that last part of
that question was to notice if alpha and
beta really are roots of this equation
that means they satisfy this equation so
for instance I can say this yeah like
that's what that's what it means for
these to be roots I can put them in and
it works ok mmm excuse me now I can
bring that idea over here I can say if
this point really is on this parabola
then I can substitute this into there
do you agree right if this point really
is on the parabola then x1 squared
that's the left-hand side equals 4a
times y1 does that make sense
like that's just at this particular
point that happens to be true
ok this fact flows directly from the
original equation and now I can bring it
to bear now you can pick up your pen on
this equation down the bottom because
look I have an x1 squared right so watch
what happens doesn't simplify all that
much but it does make it a little bit
better on the right-hand side nothing is
going to happen
yet it'll stay put but on the right hand
side I can go X X 1 and I'm going to
subtract for a Y 1 because that's what
the original equation tells me is true
yep yep yep I absolutely could I will
let you have a think like okay why did I
replace this guy with this as opposed to
this guy with something from here I'll
let you ever think as to why this is
sort of probably a more common-sense way
to go I want a simpler equation remember
but go ahead and try it and see what
happens
okay I can tidy up a little bit here
come on tie what would you like me to do
if I add for a y 1 to both sides I will
turn that into it too like so so even
though this is quite uncharacteristic
I'm actually going to make X X 1 the
subject here because this ends up
factorizing and being quite neat so I'm
gonna take X X 1 to a outside of y plus
y1 ok so it does look a bit weird but at
least it's quite simple you can see all
you need is the coordinates of your
point and the focal length of the
problem that's a very small amount of
information so that's kind of nice it's
not as elegant I don't think is the
parametric form but it still works ok we
won't finish it but just we can start it
if I had instead the equation of the
normal what would be different
okay so you can see here a few different
things are going to cancel out and
you're going to use this original
equation in a different way I'm going to
leave it to you to prove that and you
can see this ends up being used in the
exercise anyhow but I think getting this
idea here is enough brain bending for
today and you can put a big box around
that and when you do the exercise later
on get used to using it
thankfully mercifully you don't ever
have to prove that again it's on the
reference sheet okay except for if they
actually specifically asked you to
derive it but that hardly ever happens
so I'm not too worried about it no I
mean if as you can see it's like point
grainy form that's like that's stuff
from last year no big deal though the
read insights this one this is weird
we've never really done something like
this before except in this context and
it doesn't feel very much like this kind
of question but that's why I drew the
parallel for you okay